GOOD AFTERNOON NO ONE.
LIKE TO START THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE.
.
THE TABLE TO START OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE NOTICING THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE CORE DHEA COMMITTEE YOU
WILL BEGIN.
AS SUBCOMMITTEE LIKE I MENTIONED
UP BUT BEFORE WE START.
.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE SOMETIME ONCE
WE BEGIN THE COMMITTEE.
TO WELCOME BACK ON MR OBERNOLTE
AND MISTER PATTERSON SOME
WARNING YOU.
IN ADVANCE THAT WILL PLACE
STOPPER SECOND THERE AND A
WELCOME THE BACK TO COMMITTEE.
NOTICING OF THAT.
AS I SAID.
WE WANT TO WELCOME.
MISTER OBERNOLTE AS OUR VICE
CHAIR.
THE COMMITTEE ONCE AGAIN.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
MISTER WOULD WOULD BE
SUBSTITUTING FOR MR LOW. IN
TODAY'S HEARING.
AM GOING TO START WITH MR TINGS
BILL. AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN.
AND THE SERGEANT WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
.
START BY NUMBER TWO MISTER TING.
THANK YOU GOT MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO PARRY
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLE.
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU
KNOW.
FORTY PERCENT ARE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS COMES FROM THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THAT EMISSIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR COMES
FROM.
PASSENGER VEHICLES WE OBVIOUSLY
I HAVE SERIOUS GOALS TO HAVE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES FOR
GOVERNOR'S PUT OUT A NEW
EXECUTIVE ORDER ON THIS ISSUE.
HOWEVER WE DON'T EXACTLY HAVE A
ROADMAP TO GET THEIR SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE THAT ROAD MAP FOR ALL
OF US INTO GIVE US SOME DATA
INTO SOME GUIDANCE INTO THE
FUTURE. OUT WITHOUT I HAVE ON
ONE WITNESS.
IT SHOULD HAVE SAID EARLIER BUT.
THIS IS NOT TO BE UPON HERE BUT
FOR FUTURE.
PRESENTATIONS WOULD ALLOW FIVE
MINUTES FOR FIVE MINUTES
AGAINST.
CHAIR MEMBERS AYE ME SHIRAI WITH
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY WHERE
PROUD TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEENS AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN.
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTION AND I WE BELIEVE
IT'S A PRACTICAL STEP TO HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT'S NEEDED IN
TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE BUILD
OUT I'M JUST I'M KEY
DIFFERENTIATORS OF THE DATA THAT
WOULD BE COLLECTED IS THAT THIS
GOES BEYOND JUST PASSENGER
VEHICLES SO INCLUDES HEAVY. DUTY
AND OTHER VEHICLE TYPES AND WHAT
I'LL ALSO HIGHLIGHT EXISTING
GAPS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MATTHEW MARKETS WITH OFF SERIE
PARA PICKETS
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
TO PUT IN PLACE A STRATEGIC
PLANNING PROCESS IS PROBABLY THE
BEST WAY TO GO. WE ARE JR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE THE
GRAVITY. AYE WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT AYE ONE REMIND
YOU AYE NAME ORGANIZATION. AND
OPPOSITION AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT NOW BECAUSE I IT I WILL
HAVE TO.
SAY THE SAME THING TO YOU IF IF
YOU GO OVER THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CORBELS ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURST DANIELLE MILLS HERE AT THE
AMERICAN WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
EILEEN TOP ARMY HALF OF THE
FARMING CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
WE NOW HAVE A QUORUM MEDI
SECRETARY OF PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SANTIAGO.
HERE.
OBERNOLTE HERE.
BONTA.
SO BONTA THIS.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
WOULD.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
QUICKSILVER.
RODRIGUEZ.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WOULD
LIKE A A WELCOME MISTER
PATTERSON BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES GONNA
PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR FOR A FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
ESPECIALLY AT FIVE.
WE WOULD NEED A MOTION A SECOND.
WE ARE FIRST THE SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DEPOSITED COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION SANTIAGO AYE
AYE SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE BONTA.
CERVANTES.
EDUARDO GARCIA HOLDEN.
WOULD.
WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I.
SEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT MISTER WOULD AB NINETEEN
FIFTY NINE.
WELL FIRST.
WELL THE SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER WITH LIKE THE
PRESENT ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY NINE EXTENDS
THE HIGH COST FUND DAY IN FUND
BE PROGRAMS FOR FOUR YEARS THESE
PROGRAMS HELP CALIFORNIA'S
CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT BY
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE TELEPHONE SERVICE IN
RURAL HIGH COST AREAS OF THE
STATE.
WELL TO THE PROGRAMS ARE
COMPLETELY THE BY THE TWO
PROGRAMS ARE COMPLETELY SEPARATE
FROM ONE ANOTHER THEY'RE BOTH
DESIGNED AND ADMINISTERED TO
SUPPORT CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT.
EACH CARRIER OF LAST RESORT HAS
THE OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE BASIC
VOICE SERVICE CAPABLE OF MAKING
AND RECEIVING NINE ONE ONE CALLS
IN AN AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE
MANNER FOR ALL THE CUSTOMERS IN
THE SERVICE AREA AND THIS IS NO
SMALL TASK.
THE HIGHLY VARIABLE LANDSCAPE OF
CALIFORNIA POSES UNIQUE ISSUES.
AND ENSURING WIDESPREAD IN
AFFORDABLE SERVICES PROVIDING
AND MAINTAINING
TELECOMMUNICATION NETWORKS IN
RURAL REGIONS WAS SPARSELY
POPULATED AREAS PAIRED WITH THE
ROUGH TERRAIN ARE NOT LUCRATIVE
REGION'S FOR TELLING THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S COMMITTED
TO THE PRINCIPLE OF UNIVERSAL
SERVICE THE CONCEPT THAT BASIC
TELEPHONE SERVICE SHOULD BE
AFFORDABLE AND AVAILABLE TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS.
CALIFORNIA STATES COMMITTED TO
THE PRINCIPLE OF UNIVERSAL
SERVICE THROUGH THE HOUSE
CALIFORNIA HIGH COST FUND
PROGRAM.
LAST YEAR THE CPUC ADOPTED A NEW
FIRE MAP DESIGNATING EACH AREA
OF THE STATE BY ITS DEGREE OF
FIRE THREAT.
MANY OF THESE DESIGNATED PARTS
OF THE STATE A FOUND IN THE BE
FUND COVERAGE AREAS. AND ALSO
PARTS OF THE A FUND SERVICE
AREAS AB NINETEEN FIFTY NINE IS
A CRITICAL ASPECT IN ENSURING.
THESE RESIDENTS LIVING IN FIRE
PRONE AREAS HAVE ACCESS TO NINE
ONE ONE.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY NINE IS MORE
THAN JUST MAKING SURE THAT ALL
CALTRAIN STAY CONNECTED IT'S
ABOUT MAKING SURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS ARE SAFE.
I HAVE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
WITH ME CALIFORNIA'S A
INDEPENDENT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANY CAO COM AND FRONTIER TO
TESTIFY AND ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU JUST REMIND EVERYBODY
OF FIVE MINUTES FORM PLAINTIFF
AGAINST.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I MET MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I WE WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMAN WHAT FOR CARRYING
THIS BILL IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL THE LEGISLATURE OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS HAS PASSED AN
EXTENSION BILL FOR THE HIGH COST
FUNDING BE PROGRAMS. TO ENSURE
THAT RULE CALIFORNIANS STAY
CONNECTED AS YOU KNOW THE A FUND
COMPANIES ARE FULLY REGULATED BY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSIONS
WE HAVE TO FILE RATE CASES SO WE
ARE FULLY REGULATED.
AND AS MENTIONED THESE AREAS ARE
VERY TOUGH TERRAIN TYPOGRAPHY
INGRID JEER GEOGRAPHIC AREAS
MAKE IT VERY CHALLENGING OFTEN
POPULATIONS HOMES AND BUSINESSES
ARE MILES AND MILES APART.
THESE AREAS WOULD NOT BE SERVED
WITH AFFORDABLE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES WITHOUT THE ASSISTANCE
IN PARTNERSHIP OF THE UNIVERSAL
SERVICE PROGRAM AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
COSTS FUND A. PROGRAM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA
WITHOUT THE THIS PROGRAM IT IS
NOT ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE TO
SERVE THESE AREAS WE'VE SHARED
WITH MANY OF YOU THAT SOME OF
THE OF THE COST COULD BE AS MUCH
AS TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. FOR
CUSTOMER JUST TO HAVE A
TELEPHONE LINE TO BE ABLE TO
CALL NINE ONE ONE. WE ARE
CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT WERE
OBLIGATED TO BE IN THESE AREAS
AND SERVE IN OUR AREAS SO TODAY
WILL BE SERVING TOMORROW WILL BE
SERVING WERE GOING TO ENSURE
THAT OUR CUSTOMERS ARE SERVED.
WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
TO ENSURE THAT OUR RURAL AREAS
STAY CONNECTED. AS YOU KNOW WE
OFTEN VACATION WE OFTEN GO
YOSEMITE KIRKWOOD WE'VE ALL BEEN
TO THESE PLACES THESE ARE ALL A
FUND AREAS. AND WE ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE TO MAKE SURE THAT CITIZENS
AND BUSINESSES ARE CONNECTED
THINKING.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE.
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD OF
THE BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
ABOUT AFFORDABILITY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY AS AUTHOR MENTIONED ON
THEY THEY GUARANTEE THAT THERE
IS ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE VOICE
SERVICE AND ABILITY TO CALL NINE
ONE ONE. A AND B. FUND SUPPORT
IS PROVIDED TO CARRIERS OF LAST
RESORT ONLY FOR THOSE HIGH COST
CENSUS BLOCKS
WHERE THE COST OF PROVIDING
SERVICES ABOUT THIRTY SIX
DOLLARS A MONTH.
FRONTIERS BASIC BASIC RATE FOR
EXAMPLE IS TWENTY TWO DOLLARS
BUT WITHOUT BE FUN SUPPORT IT
COULD BE TRIPLE THAT AMOUNT TO
RECOVER COSTS AND IN SOME CASES
BETWEEN HUNDRED AND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS. AND SECONDLY AS THE
AUTHOR POINTED OUT THIS.
THE BE FUN ESPECIALLY IS REALLY
ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY BOTH
PROGRAMS ACTUALLY. BUT IF YOU
TAKE THE NEW P. UC FIRE MAP AND
LOOK AT WHERE TE HIGHEST FIRE
DANGER AREAS AND YOU OVERLY THAT
WITH THE HIGH COST.
FUND BE FUN CENSUS BLOCKS
IT'S LIKE A VERY STRONG DIRECT
CORRELATION SO PRESERVING THE
ABILITY TO HAVE AFFORDABLE
SERVICE WHERE THESE UP RESIDENTS
CAN CALL NINE ONE ONE WHEN A
FIRE BREAKS OUT ANOTHER
EMERGENCY. THIS BILL REALLY
PRESERVES OUT AND.
ADVANCES PUBLIC SAFETY SO AGAIN
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
MEMBERS BILL DIVIDE REPRESENTING
A T. AND T. I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY WE ARE
ALSO A CARRIER OF LAST RESORT
AND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW. WE ARE
ALSO THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF
BASIC TELEPHONE SERVICE UP TO
RURAL CALIFORNIA I JUST WANTED
TO ADD A COUPLE OF ITEMS HERE TO
THE CONVERSATION THE GOAL HERE
IS TO KEEP BASIC SERVICE
AFFORDABLE REGARDLESS OF WHERE
YOU LIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROGRAM IS ALSO
COMPETITIVELY NEUTRAL WHILE WE
ARE CARRIERS OF LAST RESORT AND
WE PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
ANY COMPANY CAN VOLUNTEER TO
BECOME A CARRIER OF LAST RESORT
AND ALSO QUALIFY FOR THIS
SUPPORT IF THEY CHOOSE TO SERVE
THESE HIGH COST AREAS.
LAUGHS DOT THE LAST
INVESTIGATION BY THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION OF THIS
PROGRAM WAS OPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE. IT WAS A FIVE
YEAR DOCKET AND IT WAS CONCLUDED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN
THERE WERE NO SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES RECOMMENDED TO THE
PROGRAM AT THAT TIME. SO WE DO
NOT SUPPORT ANY ADDITIONAL
CHANGE TO THE PROGRAM.
UP FINALLY.
AND THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS THE
BE FUND IN PARTICULAR IS RUNNING
A HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR SURPLUS.
SO BASED UPON CURRENT
EXPENDITURES FROM THE FUND
THERE'S ENOUGH FUNDING THERE TO
LAST AN ADDITIONAL EIGHT YEARS
AND I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A
FIVE YEAR EXTENSION.
SO THEY'LL BE NO ADDITIONAL FEES
OR TAXES APPLIED TO THE PHONE
BILL FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
FROM THIS PROGRAM UNLESS THE
COMMITTEE IN THE P. YOU SEE
CHOOSE TO RAISE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE.
I WITH THAT WE LET OUR SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
IT ONE MINUTE LEFT.
PAN LIMITS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S INDEPENDENT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
AND.
ALL OF THE MEMBERS OF THE I. T.
C. RECEIVE A FUND SUPPORT IT.
AND I'LL JUST ADD THAT THAT.
HERE THE P. C. IS DIRECTED BY
THE STATE LEGISLATURE TO BE A
GOOD STEWARD OF THE A FIND AND
PART OF THAT STEWARDSHIP IS.
ABOUT CREATING A RATE BASE THAT
THE PHRASE THAT KIND OF EXPENSE
THAT WOULD BE OTHERWISE PICKED
UP BY THE A FUND. AND I HAD THE
TOWN CENTERS WHERE THE
POPULATIONS ARE CENTERED OR THE
LOCAL BUSINESSES ARE ON MAIN
STREET. I REALLY ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF DEFYING THE
COSTS THAT THE STATE WOULD
OTHERWISE. A BEAR FOR AS SERVING
THE MORE FAR FLUNG RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS IN THE RURAL AREAS SO
WE JUST ADD THE A FUND COMPANIES
ARE.
PROUD TO BE GOOD STEWARDS OF
THE THE PUBLIC FUNDS THAT ARE
ENTRUSTED TO THEM TO PROVIDE. A
HIGH QUALITY SERVICE IN THE
RURAL AREAS THEY SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT REMIND YOU
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITIONALLY.
TRACY RYAN ROLL COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
CHARITY IS REPRESENTING OFFICER
REPAIR ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
RHONDA ARMSTRONG REPRESENTING
CARMEN TELEPHONE COMPANY IN
FOREST HILL TELEPHONE COMPANY
WERE IN SUPPORT.
BRENDA SHEPHERD REPRESENTING
VOLCANO TELEPHONE COMPANY WERE
IN SUPPORT.
REGION ACOSTA REPRESENTING TURN
WORD SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON BERNIE ROSCOE AT
HELPING TO CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION.
WANTED TO JUST A MOMENT A
POSSIBLE ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
THAT THE HIGH COST ON A IN THE
PROGRAM TO DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
HERE WE HAVE A POSITION ON A
SEPARATE ON FOR EACH PROGRAM.
SO WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
AND.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS OVER
THE YEARS IN THE PAST WE HAVE
BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THE PROGRAM'S
BEEN A GOOD PROGRAM?
BUT IT DISTINCTION BETWEEN.
THE THE CARRIES OF LAST RESORT
AND IN OUR INDUSTRY IS.
WE ARE FACILITIES WERE NOT BUILT
WITH REPAIR FUNDS
SO THERE IS AN OBLIGATION ON
SOME FOLKS THAT HAVE USE RATE
HERE FUNDS OVER THE YEARS TO
BUILD THESE NETWORKS.
SO IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE SOME SORT OF
OBLIGATION.
AND SO WE WE PUT SUPPORT OF THAT
THE PAST SERVICE WAS REALLY
WANTS.
TO GET HOME.
.
WHAT WE WERE LOOKING AT ON HIGH
COSTS FUND A PROGRAM SO THESE
ARE THE SMALL RURAL ILEX CENTER?
AT ABOUT THIRTEEN OF THEM IN THE
STATE.
AS WE EXPAND OUR FACILITIES OUT
TO THE RURAL AREAS AND HE'S ERIC
ROYER HAS BECOME MORE POPULATED
WE HAVE FACILITIES THERE SO WE
ARE IN SOME OF THESE THESE
COMMUNITIES TODAY. AND ALL THAT
WE'RE ASKING IS THAT WE BE ABLE
TO EFFECTIVELY COMPETE WITH
EVERYONE ELSE BECAUSE IT DOES
AREAS ARE PROTECTED AT THIS
POINT.
SO OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENT THAT
WE'RE SUGGESTING TODAY IS THAT.
.
THE COMMISSION. IN REVIEWING
SOME STUDIES COMPARATIVE STUDIES
BETTER INDIVIDUALIZED FOR EACH
OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
THAT WITHIN SIX MONTHS OF THAT
FINAL REPORT THAT THEY JUST TAKE
A LOOK AND MAKE A DETERMINATION
WHETHER OR NOT THAT COMMUNITY
SHOULD BE OPEN TO COMPETITION.
AND THAT'S IT NOW THE COMMISSION
COMES BACK AND SAYS NO WE DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S ENOUGH
COMPETITION IN THIS COMMUNITY
THAN FIND THEN WE WILL LIVE WITH
THAT. SO THAT'S OUR FIRST MET
FOR THE HIGH COST BUT HEY.
THE HIGH COST FUND BE COMMUNITY
SO THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
PROGRESSIVELY.
.
REDUCE ITSELF IN NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN IS ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS TODAY
IT'S A PROBABLY ABOUT TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TODAY. BUT
WE'RE LOOKING AT MORE MORE
COMPETITION LOWER THAN THOSE
RURAL AREAS
AND WE JUST BELIEVE IT IS TIME
THAT WE ALSO.
SHOULD HAVE EQUAL FOOTING IN A
COMPETITION IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
SO ALL THAT WE'RE ASKING AND
THAT AMENDMENT IS THAT THE PC.
ONCE AGAIN A PAUSE AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THE HIGH COST FUND A
COMMUNITIES AND SAY. IS THIS A
PRO THAT'S WORTHY OF
CONTINUATION.
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS FROM
THE LEGISLATURE IS A DESIRE TO
BUILD MORE AND MORE RURAL
BROADBAND WE HAVE?
RIGHT NOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS APPROVED OVER
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
TELEPHONE CORPORATIONS IN THE
RURAL AREAS TO BUILD OUT THEIR
FACILITIES NOW IT'S FOR
BROADBAND BUT YOU WOULD GET
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
WITH THAT AS WELL.
JUST LAST YEAR THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED AND THE MISTER CHAIR
YOU HELPED ORCHESTRATE THE
PASSAGE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICES FUND. THAT'S
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE NIGHT I REALIZE
HE'S OUR INFRASTRUCTURE DOLLARS
HE'S ARE NOT SUBSIDIES TO OFFSET
BUT THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT CAN
HELP REDUCE OPERATIONAL COSTS.
SO AT THIS POINT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS PC JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
THE HIGH COST FUND BE.
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION ALL THE
NEW FUNDS THAT ARE COMING IN
FROM THE FAT IN FROM THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND DECIDE IS THIS
REALLY A PROGRAM. THAT SENDS THE
RIGHT SIGNAL TO COMMUNICATIONS
SERVICE WRITERS THAT WE PUT
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
WOULD WANT TO ENSURE THAT.
BROADER ADVANCED COMMUNICATION
SERVICES ARE BEING DEPLOYED NOT
MAINTAINING A PAY BASIC
TELEPHONE LINE SO THAT'S UP FOR
WITHOUT THE TO MEMBERS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JAMES JACK ON BEHALF OF
CAL TELL A UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS WELL BECAUSE
CAL TELL DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
IT'S APPROPRIATE. TO EXTEND ANY
FURTHER A FUND SUBSIDIES TO
PROVIDERS AS LONG AS THESE
PROVIDERS STILL ENJOY A MONOPOLY
PROTECTION FROM THE PVC.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
ORDERED THAT ALL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS MARKETS BE
OPEN TO COMPETITION NO LATER
THAN JANUARY FIRST NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN.
IT'S UNIMAGINABLE THAT OVER TWO
DECADES LATER THIS IS STILL NOT
OCCURRED IN CALIFORNIA IS A FUN
MARKETS.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE PC
DECIDED TO STUDY WHETHER TO OPEN
THESE MARKETS TO COMPETITION.
IT'S NOW TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE
HAVE NO STUDY AND NO ACTION.
OPENING TELCO MARKETS TO
COMPETITION ACROSS CALIFORNIA
HAS RESULTED IN TREMENDOUS
CONSUMER BENEFIT IN PRICE
SERVICE AND INNOVATION.
YET THESE A FUN TERRITORIES ARE
THE ONLY MARKETS LEFT IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WERE PROVIDERS
ARE STILL PROTECTED UNDER
ANTIQUATED MONOPOLY SYSTEM.
EVEN THOUGH WERE PROHIBITED BY
STATUTE FROM RECEIVING THE A
FUND SUBSIDY WE WANT TO COMPETE
AGAINST THESE PROVIDERS DESPITE
THE FACT THAT THEY RECEIVE.
A SIXTY DOLLAR MONTHLY A FUND
SUBSIDY BUT CAL TELL SIMPLY
CANNOT.
SUPPORT CONTINUING IN A FUN
PROGRAM WHERE CAL TELLS
RATEPAYERS
SUBSIDIZE MONOPOLY PROVIDERS IN
AREAS WHERE CAL TELL MEMBER
COMPANIES AREN'T ALLOWED TO
COMPETE.
WE MUST OPPOSE THIS BILL UNTIL
IT IS AMENDED TO RESOLVE THIS
IMPORTANT CONCERT THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN SAY WITHIN
A FIVEMINUTE I FORGOT I
NEGLECTED TO MAKE ONE FINAL
POINT. EVEN WITH OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENT FOR THE HIGH COST WHEN
A PROGRAM.
IF THE COMMISSION WERE TO OPEN
THAT.
THAT SERVICE TERRITORY FOR
COMPETITION WE WOULD ELIMINATE
THE SUBSIDIES SO WITH OUR
AMENDMENTS.
SO ALLRED SKIN IS THIS
CONSIDERATION FOR THE P. YOU SEE
MOVING FORWARD YOU WOULD STILL
THAT THE PROGRAM WOULD STILL BE
REAUTHORIZED FOR FIVE MORE YEARS
SO.
AND SO WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO
ELIMINATE THE PROGRAMMING NEATLY
WITH YOUR VOTE TODAY WITH YOUR
VOTE TODAY ALL RESTING FOR IS TO
HAVE THE PC.
A SECOND LOOK AT THIS AND SO NO
NO ELIMINATION OF THE HIGH COST
ONE A SUBSIDY EVEN IF YOU WERE
TO GO FORWARD WITH THIS.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND START.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
SO ONE OF THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ABOUT MR WORD I. THINK YOU FOR
BRING THE BILL FORWARD I AGREE
WITH YOU THAT. THIS PROGRAM IS
STILL NEEDED. AND.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY I BUT I HAD A QUESTION
BECAUSE IN IN THE LARGER CONTEXT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE THAT'S
TAKEN PLACE. SINCE THESE HIGH
COST FUNDS WERE.
PUT INTO PLACE.
SO NOW WE'VE GOT A THE
PROLIFERATION OF MOBILE PHONES
INSTEAD OF LAND LINE PHONES WE
GOT MORE AND MORE PEOPLE WHO.
THANKS TO THE EFFORTS OF A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM CAN
NOW ACCESS BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THEIR RURAL
HOMES AND ARE CHOOSING TO OUR TO
PIGGYBACK TELECOMMUNICATIONS ON
THOSE. AND SATELLITE PHONES ARE
ARE MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE RIGHT
LET MUCH LESS EXPENSIVE AND
SERVICES MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE
THAN IT EVER HAS BEEN BEFORE SO.
INEVITABLY THERE WILL COME A
TIME.
WHEN
THIS KIND OF SUPPORT IS NO
LONGER NECESSARY. AND ARE WE
DON'T HAVE TO FORCED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES TO
BE THE OUR PROVIDER OF LAST
RESORT IN THE AREAS THESE AREAS.
I IT SO MY QUESTION IS.
WHAT ARE WE GONNA BE HERE FIVE
YEARS FROM NOW REAUTHORIZING THE
PROGRAM OR IN YOUR OPINION IS
THIS?
THE LAST REAUTHORIZATION THIS
NEED AT THIS GOING TO GET US TO
THIS POINT WHERE WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO IT ANYMORE WILL HAVE LOVED
BILL TO SAY THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE HERE IN FIVE YEARS.
AND FIRST BOUGHT AND NOBODY'S
FORCES ANYBODY TO BE CAREFUL
LAST RESORT THAT'S A VOLUNTARY
YOU YOU SIGN UP FOR THIS YOU
TAKE THE FUNDS YOU YOU BECOME
YOU TAKE THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
ARM THESE ARE THE MOST DIFFICULT
PLACES TO REACH IN GENERAL AND
SO.
WHILE OUR GOAL AS YOU SAW LAST
YEAR.
WITH A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE
WITH IT IS TO GET TO NINETY
EIGHT PERCENT COVERAGE IN EVERY
REGION OF THE STATE. AND SO MY
HOPE IS THAT WILL BE IT WILL BE
MUCH CLOSER ON CAN I SAY THAT
ABSOLUTELY EVERYONE WILL BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THIS KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY NOW I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THAT FOR SURE. MY HOPE IS
THAT THE MAYBE THAT REESE AND
THE NEED FOR RESOURCES WILL BE
MUCH LESS.
THAN PURE. THAT PEOPLE WE NEED
TO SERVE SERVE WILL BE MUCH LESS
AND WILL BE MUCH CLOSER TO YOU
KNOW A HUNDRED PERCENT COVERAGE
OF EVERYONE WITH A DIFFERENT
LEVEL OF SERVICE.
WELL I. CERTAINLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT WE STILL WE'RE NOT THERE
YET. I'M HOPEFUL LIKE YOU THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE THERE IN FIVE
YEARS I'M NOT SURE MY ANSWER
FIVE YEARS FROM NOW WILL BE MY
ANSWERS TODAY BUT. HAVE TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
I HOPE I LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
CONVERSATION.
MR MATHIS.
THE SWELLING THE AUTHOR MISSED
WORDS OFFERING THIS FOR AND I
KNOW MY FOLKS A BACK HOME WITH
YOU CORD TELEPHONE.
WHO SERVE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF FOLKS WHO LIVE?
UP IN THE HIGH SIERRAS.
AND WAY OUT MIL OF NO WHERE.
DEFINITELY THANK YOU FOR KEEPING
THEIR RATES DOWN WITH THIS BILL
STUFF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
AFFORDABLY SPORTING.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
JOINT CLOSE.
THAT SAY THAT TED THE
CONTINUATION OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNICATION SERVICES ARE
AVAILABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS ON
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
WE ALREADY HAD A FIRST AND A
SECOND.
.
THIS MEASURE ENJOYS THAT YOUR
SUPPORT MEANT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
BUSH'S DO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SANTIAGO AYE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE BONTA CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I WOULD TRY WOULD AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I'VE ADREUS.
RODRIGUEZ I.
ELEVEN ZERO MEASURES OUT.
MISTER WOOD WOOD TO CONTINUE IN
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWENTY NINE TEN.
MY PLEASURE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I FIRST WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND SIX SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THE
DEVASTATING FIRES THAT RATE
RAVITCH CALIFORNIAN LATE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN THE STATE
AND THE CPUC ARE FOCUSED HEAVILY
ON UTILITIES RESPONSE TO MASSIVE
TO THE MASSIVE DESTRUCTION.
HARPER LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT THE
IMPACT.
THESE NATURAL DISASTERS HAVE
HAD ON THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS AND HOW
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
HAVE RESPONDED.
WHILE WE AGREE THAT THE CPUC HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION SPECIFIED IN THIS
BILL THE CPU ES CPUC IS NOT
REQUIRED TO REPRODUCE A REPORT.
TO DATE THE CP YOU SEE HAS NEVER
REPRODUCE SUCH A REPORT.
WE HAVE BEEN LEFT IN THE DARK
WHEN IT COMES TO UNDERSTANDING
THE TECHNOLOGY THAT MAY BE USE
TO REBUILD INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
NORTH BAY. AND WHETHER COMPANIES
HAVE TEMPORARY FIXES IN PLACE OR
INSTEAD INVESTED IN PERMANENT
UPGRADES WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION THERE'S NO WAY TO
ENSURE THAT RESIDENTS WILL HAVE
THE SAME OR IMPROVED ACCESS. TO
A RELIABLE NETWORK.
ON OCTOBER TENTH THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DE IT DECLARED
A LOCAL EMERGENCY IN MY DISTRICT
DUE TO WIDESPREAD.
BUT A SERVICE FAILURE IS CAUSED
BY THE NORTH BY FIRES. AND THAT
WASN'T IN THE COUNTIES THAT WERE
ACTUALLY ON FIRE.
THAT WAS NORTH OF US.
THE OUTAGES SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPACTED EMERGENCIES SERVICES
AND GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE
AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
PUBLIC SERVICES.
AB TWENTY NINE TEN WOULD REQUIRE
THE CPUC TO REPORT TO THE
APPROPRIATE POLICY COMMITTEE OF
THE LEGISLATURE. THE IMPACT OF A
NATURAL DISASTER ON THE STATE'S
TELECOMMUNICATIONS NETWORK AND
THE RESPONSE OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES.
AS TIME PASSES IT'S UNLIKELY
THAT DAMAGED OR DESTROYED
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE
REPLACED.
IT IS LIKELY EXCUSE ME IT IS
LIKELY THAT THERE THEY WILL BE
REPLACED. THERE IS STRONG PUBLIC
INTEREST ENSURING THAT NEWER
EQUIPMENT RESULTS IN IMPROVED
AND MORE RESILIENT SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE WHAT
NOT REQUIRED TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES TO DIVULGE
INFORMATION.
THAT WOULD BE HARMFUL TO
SECURITY SUCH AS TO DISCLOSURE
ADDRESSES A PROPOSED NETWORK
FACILITIES.
LOCATIONS OR AN ITEMIZED LIST
OF THE ACTUAL EQUIPMENT THAT'S
BEEN DEPLOYED.
THE FACT THAT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
LINES ARE DAMAGED OR AN EXTENDED
OUT IS TAKES PLACE DURING
NATURAL DISASTERS. INCLUDING
OUTAGES AFFECTING NINE ONE ONE
SERVICES IS NOT A SECRET SUCH
OUT PROFIT SUCH OUTAGES ARE
OFTEN REPORTED IN THE MEDIA. AND
TRUST ME I GET PHONE CALLS FROM
PEOPLE ABOUT THIS AS WELL.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE DISCLOSURE OF
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION TO BE
HARMFUL THE PUBLIC SAFETY I WILL
BE WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS
TO ENSURE THAT SUCH INFORMATION
IS PROTECTED. CONTAINED IN THIS
REPORT.
I RECEIVED THE OPPOSITION'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS LATE
YESTERDAY AND HAVE BUT NOT HAVE
A TIME TO FULLY REVIEW THEM.
SHOULD THIS BILL MOVE FORWARD
THROUGH THE PROCESS WILL COMMIT
TO WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
REGINA COSTA A WITH TURN AND
KEITH GIBSON LOCAL PRESIDENT AND
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
POLICY CHAIR. OF CALPERS A
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
REGINA COST ON THE TELECOM
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK AND WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS
BILL. AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE MEMBERS
REPRESENTING AREAS HIT BY
NATURAL DISASTERS ARE FULLY
INFORMED ABOUT COMMUNICATION
OUTAGES CAUSED BY THESE EVENTS.
THE EXTENT THE DURATION THE
IMPACT ON NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
AND HOW THE SERVICE IS BEING
RESTORED.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT REPORTING.
WHEN OUTAGES OCCUR LEGISLATORS
NEED TO BE INFORMED ABOUT THE
EXTENT AND WHERE THE OUTAGES OF
TAKEN PLACE WHEN IT WAS RESTORED
FOR DIFFERENT AREAS. AND WHETHER
THE TEMPORARY OR PERMANENT MEANS
WERE USED TO RESTORE THAT
SERVICE.
AND IF A TEMPORARY SOLUTION IS
IN PLACE THEN WHAT'S THE LONG
TERM PLAN.
THE BILL IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
YOU NEED TO KNOW WHETHER THERE
ARE POCKETS OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO HAVE SUFFERED LONGER TERM
OUTAGES.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AT SOME
POINT.
TURN HAS BEEN ACTIVE ON THESE
ISSUES FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE
HEARD FROM NUMEROUS CUSTOMERS
WHO HAVE LOST SERVICE IN FIRES
AND IN LARGE STORMS. WHO HAVE
HAD THEIR SERVICE?
OUT OF OUT OF SERVICE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
OUR MOST RECENTLY WILL VARY IT
FAIRLY RECENTLY WE HEARD FROM
FOLKS IN BIG SUR.
WHO A LOT SERVICE AND FIRES BUT
THAT SERVICE WAS NOT RESTORED
FOR WEEKS AND IN SOME CASES
MONTHS?
THIS IS THE TYPE OF INFORMATION
THAT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE.
.
WHAT THE BILL WILL NOT DO IT
WILL NOT RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
REGULATION OR PROCEEDINGS AT THE
COMMISSION?
THE SIMPLE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE
ACCURATE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF DISASTERS ON ON THESE
FACILITIES AND SERVICES AND
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
RESTORATION.
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
CHAIRMAN SANTIAGO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
MY NAME IS KEEP GIVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA LOCAL NINETY
FOUR TWELVE REPRESENTING
DISTRICT NINE WHICH INCLUDES
CALIFORNIA NEVADA AND HAWAII.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA CW A
REPRESENTS MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CUSTOMER
SERVICE MEDIA AIRLINES PUBLIC
SERVICE AND MANUFACTURING.
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE TEN AS
A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY GOOD JOBS
AND UPGRADING OF THE
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS AFTER
NATURAL DISASTERS.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THAT THE
P. YOU SEE TO REPORT ANNUALLY TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON HOW
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS RESTORE.
BUT SERVICE TO THE COMMUNITY
AFTER THE DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY IT WOULD ALSO
AUTHORIZE THE COMMISSION TO
REQUIRE TELECOMMUTE CASES
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE ANY
RELEVANT INFORMATION. TO THE
COMMISSION.
I'M PROUD OF THE THOUSANDS OF
SAID CW A MEMBERS EMPLOYED BY
EIGHTEEN T. WHO WORK LONG HOURS
TO GET BOTH LANDLINE AND
WIRELESS EMERGENCY SERVICE UP
AND RUNNING. AND QUICKLY AS
QUICKLY AND SAFELY AS POSSIBLE.
NOW WITH THE IMMEDIATE CRISIS
BEHIND US.
POLICY MAKERS IN THE PUBLIC NEED
TO KNOW WHAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANY ARE
DOING TO REBUILD THE DAMAGED
NETWORKS.
OR THE COMINT PROVIDERS MEAN
THEIR STATUTORY CARRIER OF LAST
RESORT OBLIGATION BY REPAIRING
THE NETWORK TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS ACCESS TO QUALITY
FOR SERVICE.
ARE THEY USING THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UPGRADE THE
NETWORKS WITH FIBER TECHNOLOGY
AND IF SO WHERE.
OR ARE THEY SIMPLY SPEAKING WITH
TEMPORARY FIXES IN PLACE FOR THE
PERMANENT UPGRADES THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE THE LEGISLATIVE THE
CPUC AND THE PUBLIC WITH
INFORMATION WHICH IS NEEDED. TO
ANSWER THESE QUESTIONS.
S. AB TWENTY NINETEEN IT WOULD
GIVE THE LEGISLATIVE THE CP YOU
SEE THE PUBLIC THE INFORMATION
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
REPAIR. OF TELECOMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE DAMAGE DURING
NATURAL DISASTERS
MEETS THE STATUTORY OBLIGATION
AND PROMOTES PUBLIC SAFETY
DEPLOYMENT OF HIGH SPEED
BROADBAND NET NETWORKS AND GOOD
JOBS.
IF THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
CONFIDENTIALITY FOR COMPETITIVE
REASONS I'M SURE THE CONCERNS
CAN BE ADDRESSED YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE
MEMBERS.
IN THIS HEARING TODAY WHO'VE
LOST THEIR HOUSES DUE TO THE
FIRE THEY NEED TO KNOW WHEN
THEIR SERVICE IS GOING TO BE
RESTORED THANK YOU.
THE MARKETS WITH THE OFFICER A
PAIR OF TICKETS WERE.
BE HERE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ALL BE
VERY QUICK ABOUT THIS THIS BILL
WOULD HELP ADVANCE THE STATE
SAFETY GOALS BY PUTTING KEY
INFORMATION BEFORE YOU THE
DECISION MAKERS.
TWO MAKE WELL INFORMED DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW TO TREAT THE SERVICE
OUTAGES.
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
I THINK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ONCE AGAIN
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY.
TRADING RYAN ON THE ROLE COUNTY
REPRESENTS A CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
MORGAN KARBALA ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
BILL DEVINE AND I STILL
REPRESENT EIGHTEEN TAKE.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
I ALSO WANNA MAKE AN
OBSERVATION JUST A MOMENT AGO
YOU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY. TO SEE
A MEMBERS OF CW A WHO REPRESENT
EIGHTEEN T. ANOTHER COMPANIES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
STAND UP AND AND I'D LIKE TO
MAKE THE OPRY OBSERVATION THAT
REGARDLESS OF THE FACT THAT WE
THAT WE DO AGREE OR DISAGREE ON
THIS PARTICULAR POLICY.
THESE ARE THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES DURING
THESE DISASTERS.
THEY ARE RESTORING NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I IN THE WAKE OF THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS
SO WE ARE PROUD TO HAVE THEM AS
MEMBERS OF OUR COMPANY WE ARE
PROUD TO ASSOCIATE WITH THEM AS
COLLEAGUES. SO WE THANK THEM FOR
COMING AND THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY TODAY.
ARE LET ME GET ON WITH MY
TESTIMONY WE OPPOSE OBVIOUSLY
THE BILL I DON'T THINK WE'RE
THAT FAR APART.
OUR AND WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD OF
FOLLOWING THIS HEARING TO FIND A
SWEET SPOT THAT BALANCES THE
VARIOUS INTEREST INVOLVED. WE
KNOW.
WE KNOW THAT MAINTAINING
COMMUNICATIONS DURING AND AFTER
A DISASTER IS CRITICAL FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE BEEN
DOING IT FOR A HUNDRED AND FORTY
YEARS.
WE WORK WITH FIRST RESPONDERS TO
PROTECT AND MAINTAIN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE. AND
DURING AND AFTER A DISASTER WE
WORK TO RESTORE THOSE SERVICES
WHEN DAMAGE WHETHER IT'S A
NATURAL DISASTER OR ON OCCASION
VANDALISM.
TODAY THE P. YOU SEE ALREADY HAS
TIMELY ACCESS.
THE INFORMATION BOTH PUBLIC AND
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION FROM
FCC OUTAGE REPORTS
INCLUDING OUTAGES AFFECTING NINE
ONE ONE.
FURTHER THE PEACE SHE HAS
BROUGHT EXISTING AUTHORITY IN P.
YOU CODES.
FIVE EIGHTY ONE FIVE EIGHTY TWO
AND FIVE EIGHTY FOUR THAT GIVES
THEM THE AUTHORITY TO COLLECT
ANY NETWORK DATA. THAT THEY DEEM
NECESSARY TO INVESTIGATE OUTAGES
AND NETWORK PERFORMANCE.
SO THEY HAVE THE DATA. IT'S
AVAILABLE TODAY.
ARE.
SOME OF IT.
IS PUBLIC AND SOME OF IT HAS TO
BE MAINTAINED AS CONFIDENTIAL
FOR PURPOSES OF NETWORK SECURITY
AND THAT IS A CRITICAL ISSUE.
NOW WHAT I'D LIKE TO ADD TO THE
CONVERSATION TODAY IS THE P. YOU
SEE CURRENTLY HAS A SERIES OF
PROCEEDINGS.
ALREADY UNDERWAY THE TOUCH ON
MANY OF THE ASPECTS OF WHAT.
SUPPORTERS HAVE TESTIFIED TO
TODAY THEY HAVE PROCEEDINGS OPEN
TODAY ON FIRE THREAT MAPS
HAZARD REPORTING. OUTAGE
REPORTING UNDER GROUNDING POLL
SAFETY AND MOST RECENTLY POST
DISASTER CONSUMER PROTECTION.
THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF
PROCEEDINGS AND THERE'S NO
SHORTAGE OF INFORMATION BEING
PROVIDED TO THE COMMISSION.
NOW WE UNDERSTAND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO LEGISLATORS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE COMMUNITIES IT'S IMPORTANT
HERE DISTRICTS.
THAT THE IMPACT OF THE WILD
FIRES AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS UP BE AVAILABLE TO
CITIZENS AS WELL AS THE
RESTORATION WORK IT'S GOING ON
IN THE COMMUNITIES. AND SO WE
WILL WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD TO FIND A SWEET SPOT TO
FURTHER ENHANCE THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE A
MISTAKE IF WE LEFT THE HEARING
TODAY.
WITH WITH THE MIS. THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT ALREADY BEING
PROVIDED ALREADY IN PROCESS AT
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
AND ALREADY AVAILABLE TO THIS
LEGISLATURE. ARE BASED UPON A
PHONE CALL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
HOW JACQUI CAN WITH FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS FRONTIER SHARES
THE AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO ENSURE
SAFE AND RELIABLE COMMUNICATION
SERVICE AND RAPID RESTORATION OF
SERVICE IN THE WAKE OF FIRES IN
NATURAL DISASTERS? HOWEVER WE
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AB TWENTY NINE TEN IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. PRIMARILY BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE MANY OTHER INITIATIVES
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY AT THE P. YOU
SEE AND THE LEGISLATURE RELATED
TO FIRES ENOUGH FOR DISASTERS.
THAT DIRECTLY IMPACT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
FRONTIER AND OTHER PROVIDERS ARE
FULLY ENGAGED IN THESE ONGOING
INITIATIVES AND COMPLYING WITH
EXISTING REQUIREMENTS FOR
PREVENTING FIRES REPORTING
OUTAGES RESTORING SERVICE
CAPABLE OF CALLING NINE ONE ONE.
AND RECEIVING EMERGENCY ALERTS.
TO NAME JUST A FEW FRONTIERS
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT THE VERY
COSTLY NEW INSPECTION AND
FACILITY REQUIREMENTS JUST
ADOPTED BY THE P. YOU SEE A FEW
MONTHS AGO IN THE FIRE MATT
PROCEEDING. WERE ALSO WORKING ON
CASF INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
EXPAND BROADBAND TO HIGH FIRE
DANGER AREAS AS SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTED BY THE P. YOU SEE IN
THE DECISION APPROVING FRONTIERS
FOR OUR ACQUISITION OF VERIZON.
WERE ALSO COMPLYING WITH TO P.
YOU SEE RESOLUTIONS IMPOSED POST
DISASTER IMPOSING POST DISASTER
REQUIREMENTS AFTER THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN FIRES. AND WERE
ENGAGED IN THE BRAND NEW
PROCEEDING.
AND I'D I'D WANT TO JOIN IN MY.
IN BILLS ARE URGING YOU TO NOT
VAUDEVILLE QUICKLY TO ADOPT
DUPLICATIVE REQUIREMENTS AND
ESPECIALLY TO LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
TO DO OVERSIGHT ON THE CASF
PROGRAM WHERE WE COULD GET
PROJECTS MOVING THAT WOULD BRING
BROADBAND TO HIGH FIRE DANGER
AREAS. A LOT OF THE UNSERVED
AREAS OF THE STATE THEY WIND UP
WITH WHERE THE HIGH FIRE
DANGEROUS SO WE THINK THAT IT IS
ANOTHER EFFORT THAT THIS
COMMITTEE COULD UNDERTAKE. TO
REALLY HELP US MOVE FORWARD WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE LEGISLATION YOU
ENACTED LAST YEAR ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN SIXTY FIVE. COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AGAIN AND NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS STEVE
CARLSON PROCEED TIA THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR VIOLENCE
INDUSTRY FOR THE REASONS STATED
WE. ARE WE OPPOSE.
AND BUT WE'D LIKE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH MISTER WHAT.
LORNE GREENE WENT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
ALSO HAS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
THIS OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THAT
LOOKED I THINK EVERYONE HERE ON
THE DIETS AGREEMENT. IT'S.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES GET RESTORED AFTER
NATURAL DISASTER. LA I REALLY
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR. YOUR
RESPONSE TO WHAT I THINK THE
MAIN.
ARGUMENT OPPOSITION FOR THE
BILL IS WHICH IS THAT THE P. YOU
SEE RD HAS BROAD AUTHORITY TO
REQUEST THIS INFORMATION FROM
ALL OF THE AFFECTED UTILITIES.
AND THEY CAN REQUEST AT ANY TIME
THEY WANT TO THEY DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT FOR WHAT THIS BILL DOES
WHICH IS AN ANNUAL REPORT TO BE
COMPILED THEY COULD REQUEST THE
INFORMATION RIGHT AFTER. A
NATURAL DISASTER TO BE MUCH MORE
TIMELY SO.
I DIE QUESTION I GUESS WHETHER
NOT THIS IS THE RIGHT VEHICLE
FOR TABULATING THAT INFORMATION
AND I'D LIKE TO HEAR THE
RESPONSE TO THAT ARGUMENT.
WELL YOU'RE ACTUALLY RIGHT THEY
CAN THEY CAN REQUEST INFORMATION
BUT THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT TO
PRODUCE REPORTS.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT I WANT THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT CONSUMERS.
AND KNOW THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE OUT SERVICES ARE
BEING RESTORED IN AT LEAST THE
SAME WAY. OR BETTER WAY BUT
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT FOR THE
CP FOR THE CPC TO ISSUE SUCH
REPORT EVEN THOUGH THEY CAN
COLLECT THE INFORMATION BUT
DON'T YOU THINK THE P. YOU SEE
IS JUST AS INTERESTED AS WE ARE
IN MAKING SURE THOSE SERVICES
ARE ARE RESTORED. AYE
CONSIDERING THE NUMBER OF OPEN.
OPEN ITEMS WITH THE P. YOU SEE.
AND THE TIME AT WHICH IT TAKES
FOR SOME OF THOSE FOR SOME OF
THAT TO COME OUT.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT BUT
I'D I'D I'M NOT SURE THAT.
THAT THE INFORMATION IS IS
GETTING OUT IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND AND TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
WHEN PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING
WITHOUT SERVICE. ALRIGHT WELL
FAIR ENOUGH A.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT. THE FACT
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T ONLY AN
ANNUAL REQUIREMENT THAT. ELEVEN
MONTHS COULD GO BY AFTER A
NATURAL DISASTER IN. THE DATA
THAT'S IN THE REPORT THERE
PROVIDING HOUSES THAN STALE.
I WOODS I WOULD SAY THAT.
IT'S.
MAYBE IT MEANT MAY MIGHT BE
STALE I WOULD SAY I WOULD BE
SURPRISED IF THEY COULD YOU
KNOW.
HOW HOW THAT WOULD BE PUT
TOGETHER IN A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME ANYWAY? I'M LOOK AT SOME OF
THE PROCEEDING PROCEEDINGS WE
HAVE NOW THAT THAT THAT ARE OPEN
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME. THE
INFORMATION MATE MAY INDEED NOT
BE AS FRESH AS WE WOULD LIKE IT.
AND MADE MAYBE.
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO GET MORE
YOU KNOW IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER
BUT I STILL THINK THAT
INFORMATION IS WOULD BE REALLY
VALUABLE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE IT LIKE I SAID THAT
PEOPLE ARE GETTING. THE SAME
QUALITY OF SERVICE THAT THEY
ONCE HAD AND OR BETTER.
AND AND I THINK THAT.
THIS IS ONE WAY TO.
BRING THAT TO THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTENT ATTENTION AND ENSURE THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING.
I I THINK WE ALL SHARE THAT GOAL
AND I.
PERSONALLY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE
MORE VISIBILITY MORE LIGHT SHED
ON THE TOPIC JUST NOT SURE THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT VEHICLE FOR
THE REASONS THAT
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP AND I'VE
AND I AND I PLEDGE AND AND AND
THE THE.
OPPOSITION IS ALSO PLEDGED TO
WORK WITH ME TOO TO FINE TUNE
AND AND AND COME TO A SOLUTION
ON THIS AND.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS THE FIRST
POLICY COMMITTEE.
NOT EVERY BILL IS PERFECT AT
LEAVING THIS FIRST POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT I BUT I BELIEVE
THIS INFORMATION IS APTLY
CRITICAL TO CONSUMERS.
AND NOT JUST CONSUMERS BUT ALSO
TO UP OUR EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
ARE ARE ARE AGENCIES I THINK
OUR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
HUMBLE COUNTY WOULD KINDA LIKE
TO KNOW. YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
AND WHY WHY A FIRE IN IN THE
NEIGHBORING COUNTY WIPED OUT OUR
SERVICE IN THE AND CAUSED US TO
HAVE TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY. WILL ALSO COME LIKE
TO KNOW WHY AN ENTIRE COMMUNITY
GOT WIPED OUT WE DON'T HAVE THE
RESILIENCY IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE
DON'T HAVE THE REDUNDANCY IN THE
NORTH COAST. THAT SOME OTHER
AREAS ENJOY SO WHEN PART OF A
LINE GOES OUT OF IT WIPES IT
WIPES OUT ENTIRE COUNTIES AND
IT'S SO IT'S NOT JUST. NOT JUST
THE FIRE ARM WITH WE HAVE FLOODS
WE HAVE OTHER KINDS OF
EMERGENCIES WE DON'T HAVE THAT
REDUNDANCY SO SO IN SOME AREAS
AND IN LARGER URBAN AREAS A PART
OF IT A PART OF A LINE WILL GO
OUT.
AND THEY'LL STILL HAVE SERVICE
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN FOR US IN
THESE IN THESE RURAL AREAS AND
WE'RE GETTING BETTER AND AND I
WILL SAY THAT.
THAT CERTAINLY I KNOW THAT.
THAT EIGHTEEN T. N. AND
FRONTIER HAVE BEEN INVESTING A
LOT OF MONEY.
TO UPGRADE SERVICES BUT WE'RE
NOT THERE YET AND WE NEED TO BE.
LOOKING UP FOR FOR A CONCERT.
WELL IT SOUNDS LIKE LOOK LET ME
JUST CHECK IF THERE'S ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS.
IT IT IF I AUDIT OVER I'LL JUST
WRAP UP BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE WE
HAVE THE SAME GOAL ACCOUNT. I
HAVE TO BE A NO TODAY I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU TO GET THE
BILL TO A PLACE WHERE I CAN BE A
YES.
FOR BECAUSE A AYE I THINK IT'S
IT'S A LOT OF WILL GOAL THAT YOU
HAVE.
I JUST THINK THAT THE THE
IMPLEMENTATION ITS MARK.
MISTER DONALD. YES THANK YOU AND
I THANK YOU MISTER WITH
REPRESENTING THE BILL ON A NIGHT
WE'VE HAD SOME CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS BILL YOU KNOW I
STRUGGLED WITH THIS.
FOR SURE I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT TODAY.
BOB I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT THE
MUSICAL DOOR GAME TO GO ON I
JUST WANT TIME THE INFORMATION
SO THAT WE CAN LEARN FROM. FROM
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST AND
AND MAKE THINGS BETTER FOR FOR
MY MY CONSTITUENTS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU FOR COMING FORWARD
THIS BILL.
DOCTOR WOULD JUST WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION ABOUT.
SENSITIVITY OF OF INFORMATION
THAT MIGHT BE SUBJECT TO
DISCLOSURE AND. AND HOW IT MIGHT
DIE I'M SOME IT MIGHT BE
CONFIDENTIAL FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
OR SECURITY REASONS DO YOU AGREE
THAT THAT'S A CONCERN AND.
AND TOM DO YOU HAVE TO PROPOSALS
FOR HOW TO ADDRESS THAT ARM YEAH
RIGHT I UNDERSTAND AND HEAR THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT.
I AND I WOULD LEAVE THAT IN THE
HANDS OF THE PEACE YOU SEE TO
DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT THAT
SENSITIVE OR PROPRIETARY AND
WHETHER THEY CAN RELEASE THAT
ARE NOT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
WE NEED A SECOND.
I'M SORRY FIRST AND SECOND.
WE ARE FIRST AND SECOND.
MISTER WOULD I WON'T THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL AND I
KNOW HOW HARD YOU'VE WORKED AT
AND THE COMMITMENT TO YOU MAY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION. ARE ON SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RELATES TO PROPRIETY
INFORMATION AND I'M SURE YOU'LL
BE VIGILANT ABOUT ABOUT ADDRESS
ANY OTHER CONCERNS APPEAR
REGARDING OPENING ADDITIONAL
DORSET P. YOU SEE.
AND WE'RE CONFIDENT OF BASED ON
YOUR PAST WORK IN YOUR
COMMITMENTS TO CONTINUE TO
REFINE.
LEGISLATION TO GET TO A POINT
WHERE IT'S ALMOST A NEAR PERFECT
HIS PURPOSE I CAN GET.
SOMEWHAT THANK YOU FOR THAT
DUBBED DISA THIS MEASURE ENJOYS
THE CHAIR SUPPORT.
I MEANT SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DEPOSIT AS AMENDED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO BONTA. BONTA AYE
CERVANTES
CERVANTES AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I.
WOULD.
WOULD I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NO MATHIS.
A DONALD.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
OBSERVER AYE RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ I.
NINETY THREE MEASURES UP.
AT THIS POINT WE'LL HAVE MEMBERS
HAD ON THEM SECRETARY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE.
MOTION IS DEPOSITED COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS BONTA. BONTA AYE.
O'DONNELL.
OR DONALD I.
THIRTEEN IS THERE ZERO MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES.
WE TOOK IT UP.
ITEM NUMBER TO TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SEVEN MISTER TAKING.
MOTIONS TO PASTA COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION BONTA. BONTA AYE
SO BONTA. CERVANTES SITE EDUARDO
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE. O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE QUICKSILVER.
QUICKSILVER I.
FIFTY ZERO MEASURES OUT.
THIRTEEN ZERO MESSAGE OUT
.
WE ARE RELIEVED THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THREE MINUTES
I MEAN IN TERMS